please welcome the beautiful the
talented and my old dear friend a
wonderful siena miller
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my gosh
wait do i sit here oh stop it i mean it
yeah hi
cupcake oh sienna
how are you i'm good how are you oh
life is good life is good good okay so
is it true
all the years i've known you
did your mom work yes for david bowie
yes what i know
i know i know
he is
everybody's number one was there ever i
don't think there will ever be a cooler
better more talented original human
he's astounding and i never met him
really i'm like what's the point of you
mom if you've had this like you know it
was just it was before i was born sadly
um but she used to tell these stories of
how she'd like bring him coffee in the
morning she was his assistant and he'd
be playing kind of
i don't know something on the piano and
like joe what do you think of this you
know imagine having that i i can't i
know i actually i moved into an
apartment when i did my first play here
and it was the same building that he
lived in i'd like somehow swindled like
somebody to give me this extraordinary
apartment there was like an airport
hangar i mean it was and it was empty
there was barely like there was a
mattress on the floor but i'd like
roller skate around sexy yeah but i had
a halloween party
at this apartment and somebody flooded
the bathroom which then flooded david
bowie's apartment so
he's not he didn't like me very much
well you know he's nice about it
apparently i'm sure david saw a few
things in his time he's probably
actually true he's flooded people's boss
100
uh speaking of like uh you know timeless
icons um is it true that you
met the one and only i one of you know
pop culture's uh most famous fashion
models twiggy
you worked with her husband and then got
to know her yes i love her they're like
i call them mom and dad
wow imagine having that as your
surrogate mom i can't i love her you
have worked with
literally every amazing leading man in
hollywood we were going through like
the list i mean
youtube
channing tatum
bradley cooper
jimmy fallon
ben affleck
like everyone is it been so fun
so fun
they're all great aren't they i mean on
the whole i don't think i've ever worked
with somebody where i was like well i
mean a couple maybe but there's a few
that squeak in couple of creepers but on
the whole
on that list certainly they're all just
delightful um and was there a guy that
you would work with again
like that surprised you i would work
with all of them again i'm close with
bradley i've worked with him twice i
love him
um but ben affleck was like my brother
i've never laughed so much in my life
really i mean that sounds like a
ridiculous thing to say and like a
name-dropping thing to say but i
actually mean it we had zero chemistry
whatsoever it was hysterical we were
supposed to sort of be in love we were
like could not be less attracted to each
other
which was hysterical he has an enormous
head i have a small one
so like they'd have to like put me
slightly ahead of him in two shots but i
promise you and he directed the movie
and i i could barely look at him for
laughing the whole time okay so i
am
freaking out about the new show i am so
happy i can't i wait until you guys get
your teeth and hands on this show it is
classic david kelly um bruna who's done
big little lies with him and uh worked
with rhys for many years yeah um this
show has it all it's first of all what a
phenomenal cast like whoa it's you and
michelle dockery and rupert friend um
who's so appealing and handsome and
naomi scott just incredible like one
great
exciting actor after another
but
i had lots of feelings watching it i
couldn't believe when it ended how
hungry i was for more
good oh i'm so happy why do you think it
has that hook well david e kelly he
co-wrote it with melissa james gibson
so it's really propulsive and compelling
and
you know it's about there are lots of
twists i got the script and i was you
know daunted by six scripts which it
takes a while to read and i couldn't
stop reading them it's just i just
didn't see what was coming and i loved
that i loved it
[Music]